est-ce que ça révèle l'impuissance de
l'Union européenne alors l'Union
européenne
est acteur mais en quelque sorte
géopolitique
elle constate elle dénonce très
fortement hein on a pris une résolution
adoptée une très très large majorité
hein il y avait 17 compre et 570 pour
condamnation très claire des actes
terroristes du Hamas d'une violence
inouï respect enfin reconnaissance du
droit Israël de se défendre mais dans le
respect des règles internationales qui
disent qu'il ne faut pas attaquer des
cibles civiles sans lien avec le le
conflit mes droits à se défendre et
demande de maintien d'aide humanitaire à
Gaza d'ailleurs l'Union européenne est
avec les États-Unis hein ce sont les
deux principaux financeurs de du soutien
à Gaza soutien éducatif soutien sur les
les les différentes constructions
nécessaires logement équipement public
et aussi pour l'aide alimentaire donc
l'Europe puissante elle est dans cette
position équilibrée qu'au fond a bien
redéfendu Emmanuel Macron lors de sa
visite il y a quelques jours en aller
l'envoir on va par benamin netanah mais
aussi d'autres on va en parler mais sur
sur l'Union européenne il y a eu aussi
une résolution de l'ONU votée il y a
quelques jours qui appelit là aussi à
une trêve humanitaire sur les 27 pays de
l'Union européenne neuf ont voté pour
dont la France trois ont voté contte 18
se sont abstenus est-ce que c'est pas la
preuve qu'il y a une absence de ligne
CLA et comment avoir une diplomatie
efficace avec une telle absence de Line
clair alors vous savez que cette cette
résolution en fait il y avait un
amendement par un état c'était le Canada
je crois qu'il aurait rééquilibré et
aurait pris mieux en compte les
l'ensemble des éléments de de la
situation ça nécessite une majorité des
2/ers il y avait une majorité simple
l'amendement n'a pas été adopté d'où un
clivage lié plutôt à une sensibilité
dans le lien avec Israël cette ces
différentes sensibilités qui sont liées
à l'histoire de chaque pays EUR européen
c'est une réalité c'est pour ça aussi
que quand on arrive ensemble à rédiger
une résolution elle est puissante et
équilibré par nature hein parce que elle
prend en compte les différents aspects
et les différentes sensibilités entendre
elle réussi à se faire entendre
aujourd'hui l'Union européenne dans ce
conflit
elle a une posture qui
est condamné clairement le terrorisme
insupportable inadmissible dire
qu'Israël a le droit de se défendre
c'est un État souverain qui peut se
défendre
mais en respectant des règles pas pas
mettre en péril des des des milliers des
dizaines de milliers de personnes et
soutien de base j'ai envie de dire vital
à une population dont on voit qu'elle
souffre maintenant on parle de plus d'un
million de personnes déplacé il y a plus
d'eau plusélectricité plus de soins euh
et et donc c'est cet équilibre que nous
défendrons alors des position modérées
c'est toujours plus difficile à défendre
que des des positions tranchées mais
c'est parce que l'Europe
fondamentalement elle souhaite aller
vers un processus de paix alors est-ce
qu'il est possible
maintenant